Kathy pppp Tabata 30 PT 2 2 2 2 da what
are you doing so so what are you doing
what are you looking at there's nothing
to look at and then you're looking at my
hand is this what you're looking at yeah
sorry
pets are so cute sometimes you just you
just want to squeeze until they're like
eyes are about to pop out today happens
to be JT news day TIFF is already gone
for the day
and so every Jay King news or JK party
day I get to play stay-at-home dad and
that's my workstation for the day it's
kind of cool me and TIFF get to like
take turns being like the dedicated
parent for Issac on the weekdays every
Tuesday and Thursday that's J key news
and JK party I don't necessarily have to
be in them and so I take that time to be
the primary guardian of Isaac and on top
of that it's time for pixel icky today
so I'm gonna have to get a rat and my
hair this is the longest my hair has
been especially like the side it's
growing over the year no actually very
excited it's like gonna be my highlight
for the week is getting this haircut is
my hair's been bothering me for a while
now
is it easier to do someone's hair from
that perspective
really yeah because every time like a my
final wish I can I can't do it like you
do it I can't do it yeah I think he's
maybe because it is maybe better about
this side and go cheer I'm just I just
finished my haircut and now on the
picking up Isaac from school
just pick the poison yep right now we're
going to get pixels of food aren't we
yeah we're gonna do that and then come
back and get Isaac a haircut seems like
the flavor seems like a plan what's the
first thing you said when you picked you
up you're lucky if we couldn't fit our
schedules in with Uri to have both of us
back-to-back we broke our haircut
appointments and the two pawns your hair
looks good then when it's long your hair
looks good both long and short unlike
mine mine looks terrible when it's long
he's way better when it's short you
think you're handsome there you go pick
a rat dude that's how your turn
they don't scratch you well they're nice
yeah they don't bite always have a fear
of trying that
even this guy what yeah oh my god is a
big rat yeah that's very morbid you
named him and you developed a
relationship fifty-two rat no I just
treat him good that's all yeah
don't grow too fond of them
thank you sir feet got pixel some food
and now what do you want to eat I don't
know I know you what do I hate i'm
Napper subway you know what I think
getting pretty fat lately I think I need
to start eating some healthy foods
officially need to start eating like a
rabbit like rabbit food rabbit food they
eat really healthy eat carrots lettuce
but you're right though I hate subway so
much dang no I eat subway for us for
health to health do all our we're trying
to find a subway and Isaac actually
found one right there oh no really
that's subway I mean there's a sign for
Subway it's it's I think it's right over
here this thing right here is building
see ya I think it's right around here
somewhere we see it yeah it's right all
right you turn enjoy your rabbit food I
got the double meat yeah we could just
heavy
you have a like tomato on your nose
inside your nostril right there
oh my god looks like a booger betting
it's tomato yes you get your boy yeah
you're here now to beat up time to go
feed pixel
sorry if any of y'all for squeamish
we're fine accrual that's just how it is
as a snake owner careening into a
chrysalis watch this
that's a chrysalis okay oh you're
learning all these words I don't even
know anymore
that's a chrysalis as a cocoon hatch
we have some tiny wings time to get your
hair cut boy your favorite songs you get
the same haircut yep
would you ever shave your head no why
not
I may look cool on you here like your
hair I love it hey you look good
Jerri you enjoy cutting men's or women's
air more oh sorry day sure
oh how come because I get bored oh
that's true we do the same thing over
and over and over like they also
probably doing sink hole I can only do
so much true you like cutting Isaac's
texture hair or Asian texture hair yeah
the wrong clients helped us actually I
don't know how to get rid of all of them
over again what's your favorite part of
the haircut
Clark this part
Oh Joe Joe extracts extra handsome you
know extra can get extra credit
I'll go save extra no I get the early
connector have a cry face happy mates
angry pretty good that's pretty good is
it hard working with this Thank You Yuri
see you
kid he's in play mode right now I don't
know what he's doing ready
hi I'm going to walk okay bye you're so
silly
now I gotta work what's really important
it's a gift
nice camera all right oh we can't vlog
about it what is it it's a surprise
where's pauses real quick anytime Isaac
says come let me show you something in
my room
that means this tickle fight
and you're tired I have to work I have
to work I'm like a day BR 9:19 a day
behind like two days behind on work
right now editing I literally stare at
this this I stare at every single day
there's no sugar in Cheetos shouldn't be
hyper so every Thursday
dawn comes over and helps Isaac with its
Norg and kind of gives them an extra
boost of motivation
and just in case Isaac wasn't an
attention in school don't seem to
reinforce everything you're making my
shirt red oh no sorry boy
Oh clean your hands first you get this
one dirty once I like tutoring Isaac
it's very interesting to say the least
right on cue
so before we start writing was where did
you learn about Kansas yeah anywhere and
then what else
Isaac that a fantastic job was homework
today even got a note from his teacher
saying that it was really focused which
I feel like isn't always the case but
this week it was and so I texted to if
she's doing Jake a new skill I text her
a picture of the reading log that he has
with his teacher wrote that note I sent
it to her to let her know that Isaac was
doing really good and she returned
make sure you get so what is your ideal
reward house thinking laters but I don't
know what they have I didn't like you're
in favor here my soul patch yeah like a
little bit I'm a soul brother your soul
brother oh I want to everybody dude is
excited he's walking fast
what section we going to right now going
straight to look look at Legos when I
was a kid these were my favorite moments
of being a kid two prizes what you pick
that's the one yeah what's so good about
that one cuz it has a Batmobile
you wanted a Batmobile don't you have a
Batmobile ready so I've been editing for
the past uh oh man the past three hours
Isaac's been asleep for about three
hours TIFF just came home from JK news
she's been gone the whole day and she is
tired she just came in and popped on the
bed hey maybe it was a record oh how
long do ya'll come for starting at 10:00
right that's cute oh my god you cutie do
you think it's okay mom you're home now
make you relax
whoa wow that's so much not so much she
freaks out two fares too thick I gave
her too much love jellies why is your
arm up top of that harder oh okay what's
going on okay
oh you cutie she had gone to the
bathroom so I asked his teacher and how
has he been doing she said well you know
today like the last couple days have
been a little distracted and
engine so I talked to him a little bit
more after that it seemed like it worked
and awesome my seeing these knows it
makes me so proud it makes me feel like
that's such a good kid like how did I
get so lucky with such a good kid I'm so
lucky good parent
good parent too I'm so lucky to have you
and his like to your son even though you
don't admit it you're a really good dad
really good I feel really lucky I'm give
me hope they're writing stop vlogging
this is the view that I see through you
I think oh thank you this is a little
too intimate
okay bye guys Tita my oh my oh my mail
bring you my breakdown